foreign
[Music]
members are posting videos like these on
Tick Tock but why are they doing this
I'm in the city of kulikan in the
Mexican state of Sinaloa it's home of
the cinema drugs cartel but it's also
the home to this Shrine to Jesus and
alverde who was a criminal in the 1800s
but he was thoughtful as very much a
Robin Hood figure
he is the patron saint of the
dispossessed but also of the criminal
Underwood so much so that he's known as
the Narco Saint now people come here all
the time to make an offering to
malvernay and asking him for help he's
hugely revered it's something that the
drug cartels could only ever hope of but
they do try
[Music]
videos like these are difficult to
verify but the cartel Tick Tock hashtag
on Tick Tock shows a lot of Clips
apparently showing off the lifestyle of
cartel members
the videos appear to show trucks with
stacks of white powder blocks or cars
with secret compartments for drug
smuggling but the Grim reality the
danger and violence of actual everyday
life in the cartel are nowhere to be
seen
[Music]
foreign
this video featuring members of the
Jalisco New Generation cartel the main
rival to the Sinaloa cartel shows
heavily armed gunmen in clown masks
patrolling and singing along to the
radio
[Music]
um
it seems that the days of secrecy and
mystery are well and truly over by
talking to journalists like me and by
posting videos online they're trying to
show the world the cartel culture and
even its business
it might be demystifying the cartels but
in reality what they are really doing is
glorifying a life of crime drugs and
murder
foreign